so talking about milan it's a
pharmaceutical company um
uh was from a chapter called ethical
fading
and ethical fading takes place when
there's an excessive amount of finite
mindedness in an organization
um so milan makes the epipen which has
like 99 market share um it's not the
only product but it's basically the only
product um and um uh they decided to hit
their very very very aggressive
financial goals
which if they hit them the uh a small
group of people i think was i think was
about a dozen people in the company um
would get
very rich
um
uh uh
incentivized by the by the board and so
uh what ended up happening was they
started doing things that though not
illegal or highly unethical they started
raising the price of what is basically
an essential drug for so many people um
and we see this in unfortunately we see
this across pharmaceuticals
frequently when they own a patent you
know they raise the price of the drug
500 800 a thousand percent two thousand
percent five thousand percent again not
illegal
but really uncomfortable right
um and it was all driven
by
by their own short-term desires to hit a
short-term number so that they
personally may benefit completely
ignoring the fact that it would
literally it could kill people if they
couldn't afford to get a new batch of
epipen because you need a new one every
year because they do expire
that literally someone could die
that's mind-blowing to me and that's
finite-mindedness that's one of the
negative impacts when a finite
mindedness takes hold inside an
organization because we become so
insular and think about our own success
and our own benefits and literally
become ignorant to the world around us
and when people accuse us we say things
like well you know
we didn't do anything illegal we justify
it everyone's doing it
it's the system don't blame us
you know and there's a lot less
accountability um uh patagonia as you
said is the total opposite patagonia is
a very infinite-minded organization
and is obsessive
about the outside is obsessive about
their contribution to their customer and
more important the environment um and
they hold themselves to a higher
standard than probably almost any other
company on the planet for the sourcing
of their companies to the point where
they ran
uh serious advertising asking people not
to buy their product unless they
absolutely needed it now a lot of people
were cynical and thought it was a stunt
but they genuinely meant it which is we
have this expensive product please only
buy it if you absolutely need it because
we don't want you we don't want to
create too many to waste
and they set up entire programs where if
you decided that you were done with your
your jacket they had a whole
aftermarket so you could sell it
secondhand through them
or they would take it back from you and
recycle it to make more
the point is they had a whole supply
chain just to deal with people who were
done with their their their their
clothing and even their sourcing was
more aggressive than than almost every
other company and they knew it came at
personal expense they knew it affected
the numbers and increased the costs they
knew that but to them it was worth it
and the love and loyalty that their
people have for their products the love
and loyalty that their customers have
for their products are all because goes
back to that just cause by wearing a
patagonia jacket
it's not that i just like the jacket
it's telling you something about who i
am and what i believe and i'm willing to
put make the sacrifice maybe pay the
premium for the premium product because
it's important to me and that's really
where where great loyalty lies